The Pawn Stars from the World Famous Gold
and Silver Pawn Shop on the Las Vegas strip
seem to know it all.
From muskets to coins, autographs to automobiles,
the team has the cash and charisma to woo
customers and TV audiences from around the
world.
But success in business doesn't mean perfection,
and sometimes even the best get bamboozled.
In a History Channel segment in 2010, Rick
Harrison discussed the time he was cheated
by a girl's best friend.
A man in a sharp suit was looking to pawn
a pair of diamond earrings.
Harrison asked all the right questions, and
the seller gave all the right answers—and
even had a receipt.
Harrison forked over $40,000.
But three days later, the police showed up.
Apparently, he'd actually bought some hot
diamonds, or in other words: stolen goods.
The victim got her diamonds back and the criminal
paid the price, but Harrison was out his $40K.
"That was the biggest bust I ever had in the
pawn shop," he said.
Richard "The Old Man" Harrison says fake diamonds
have swindled him the most.
When cubic zirconia, a synthetic diamond doppelgänger,
first hit the market in the seventies and
eighties, plenty of pawn shops were duped.
"Nobody knew about them, and they tested as
diamonds.
Everybody in the industry bought a bunch of
them," said Harrison in 2010.
He said he wasted nearly $30,000.
But these days, cubic zirconias don't pose
as much of a problem.
The Old Man's grandson, Corey "Big Hoss" Harrison,
even filmed a video for the History Channel
in 2009 called, "How to Spot a Fake Diamond."
Corey said that the fake rocks are "too perfect,"
adding that "There are very, very few perfect
diamonds out there."
So the seller on the street probably doesn't
own one.
He recommends examining gems under a magnifying
glass or asking a reputable jeweler to take
a closer look.
Though Corey grew up in the pawn shop, he
had to learn some business lessons the hard
way.
The Big Hoss explained: "When I first started
working the night shift, I didn't have that
much experience here, and being the typical
18-year-old kid, I thought I knew everything.
It must have got around town pretty quick
because I bought six fake Rolexes in one week."
His foolhardy ways cost him four-grand...and
really ticked off his family.
Viewers have learned there are thousands of
tricks that sellers use on fake timepieces.
Corey's dad, Rick Harrison, shared some time-tested
tips in a 2009 segment, but his bottom line
was this: "If you're going to buy a Rolex
off somebody…don't buy it off the internet.
Don't buy it off Craigslist.
Come to a guy like me if you want a used one,
or go buy a new one.
Don't buy it off the street."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw.